Speaker 1: It's great to have.
Back on the program today, Coleman Hughes,
who's a writer, opinion columnist and host
of the podcast Conversations with Coleman.
Coleman, it's great to have you on again.
Speaker 5: It's great to be on again.
Speaker 1: So okay, let let's talk about something
that's very much in the news right now.
A couple weeks ago, CNN reporter Jim Acosta
just kind of showed up and approached Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE on the
street and kind of imposed a series of questions
to her about her supposedly not remembering
things she said in the aftermath of the January
6th riots or in the immediate period before
it.
We now are in the midst of people, mostly
pro-choice protesters, showing up at the houses
of a few Supreme Court justices and protesting
at their homes.
You also told me about a situation where right
wing activist Candace Owens showed up with
a camera crew at the home of a Black Lives
Matter but person.
I kind of want to talk through your thoughts
on these techniques, and I have a few thoughts
on them, although I don't have a sort of completely
defined opinion on them.
I guess first, are these things, the three
instances I just mentioned.
Are they different or are they the same in
your mind?
And how would you approach thinking about
them?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's it's interesting to
I haven't formulated my opinion on this either.
So I guess there's one distinction to make
is approaching someone on the street as opposed
to knocking on their door.
I'm not sure either is really worse than the
other, although.
You know, one in a sense, knocking on my door
is more of an not quite an invasion of my
privacy, but a sort of questioning of coming
closer to to my private space.
On the other hand, I'm actually more protected
behind my front door than I am on the street.
And at a basic level, it's sort of no different
than a Jehovah's Witness coming and not knocking
on my front door and asking for some of my
attention.
I can simply say, No, there's nothing illegal
about it.
It's an annoyance.
And it's it's unplanned.
And there is something.
Somewhat invasive about it, but I can't say
that there's actually anything truly unethical
about it.
That would be my first pass at an opinion.
It's the kind of thing that maybe I will think
less of the journalist who opts for this as
a Plan A. But on the other hand, maybe they've
reached out to this person ten times and the
person just won't engage with any media despite
being a public figure.
So as a last resort, they're sort of trying
to catch them off guard.
Speaker 1: That last thing is interesting
to me because my instinct has generally been,
okay, this is not an approach I use.
We make all sorts of interview requests and
sometimes they're ignored or sometimes they're
turned down.
And I sort of see that as final, like the
person has turned down their opportunity to
talk to me.
Right.
But then at the same time, sometimes with
public servants or with people in positions
that you're appointed for life, you get the
feeling as just a citizen that they're in
a sense, beyond an accountability, that it
feels like maybe there should be.
So, for example, Marjorie Taylor GREENE, salary
paid by the taxpayer.
You know, we'll talk more about that because
that could apply to postal workers, too.
Or, you know, somebody at the DMV, I don't
know.
So we'll talk about whether that's relevant.
And one of 435 legislators, someone who has
an impact on policy and law, etc., and who
can just say, I'm not going to answer questions
about what some believe was her dishonesty
at this hearing that took place in Georgia.
And so is it wrong as a last resort for Jim
Acosta to show up there, the Supreme Court
justice appointed for life, essentially, I
mean, short of some kind of gross, demonstrable
misdeed, you know, there's no recourse for
saying we're going to remove a Supreme Court
justice.
Yes, they can be impeached, but it doesn't
happen.
So then you show up at the house.
I don't know that I'm like 98% of the way
to this is not okay.
And then the how do you have accountability
is where I kind of end up thinking twice.
Speaker 5: Right.
So you and I are in the same position as people
that interview a lot of people, public figures.
I don't know how many politicians necessarily,
but we're in a position where we want to talk
to a lot of people that say no to us and our
audiences want us to talk to a lot of people
that say no to us.
True.
And I completely agree with you.
Never in a million years would I show up at
someone's house or for instance, I wrote an
open letter to Ebrahim Kendi, the author,
to have a conversation with me.
And I, in fact, you know, raised a go fund
me.
I raised, you know, like 25 over $20,000 for
a charity to connect the event to that cause.
And he still didn't want to do it.
And it's of a piece with his not wanting to
talk to any of his critics, which I think
is a bad thing, but never in a million years
what I show up at this man's house or try
to cost him on the street.
And I think it's because while it's it's I
guess it's no more complicated than the golden
rule.
Like if someone wanted to talk to me and I
didn't want to talk to them and they showed
up at my apartment, I would view that as almost
hostile.
Right.
It's like as though you can say that it's
just the desire to talk, but it's the desire
to talk where they control the pace of everything.
They knew they were there prepared.
I might be in my pajamas for for all you know.
And it's it's also.
Close enough to a situation where there is
a mob outside my house where it's.
It's.
It's it's going to be very difficult for me
to be in a kind of relaxed state, to engage
with you on equal footing.
It's a little bit like shooting downhill.
It's like you have the high ground in in a
battle situation.
And I don't want to be really in that position
with someone I'm talking to.
So there is something really strange and almost
hostile about it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would say not even almost.
I mean, I don't know.
I was at a restaurant a couple of months ago
and I told the story and someone was kind
of I could tell that they recognized me.
And then as I was leaving, they approached
me and pretty loudly they said, You Jew imperialist
bastard, which didn't even accurately reflect
my views on the nuances of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, as you can imagine.
Speaker 5: But violences of imperialism, yeah.
Speaker 1: That that was not that was not
going no matter what.
That's not going to be a real conversation.
And I think maybe part of what you're getting
at is if this is the catalyst to start the
conversation, even if it's only supposed to
be a conversation, how good of one is it really
going to be?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah, definitely.
Which is, I think.
Why?
I wouldn't do it and probably why you wouldn't
do it.
But people that are more into sensationalist,
sensationalist journalism and people for whom
just getting the 62nd clip of whatever happens
is their bread and butter.
Speaker 1: Now, what about the people who
just show up?
They're not journalists.
The ones showing up at, like, you know, Kavanaugh's
house or whichever justice they're showing
up at, they're saying, well, the Supreme Court,
where all of these people are here for life,
have made a decision, assuming we've been
told the truth of the decision that's forthcoming.
They're making a decision I don't like.
There's really no recourse with these folks.
And you could say, well, you've got to make
sure at the state level then that abortion
stays legal because there won't be a federal
right and it starts to become a.
Well, maybe it is okay to show up at their
house, although I would never do that.
They would argue, what else can we really
do?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So.
In one sense, the that's actually a feature,
not a bug of American democracy, is that the
Supreme Court is supposed to be insulated
from that kind of intense public pressure.
Yes.
You know, they are one of the institutions
that separate America from a direct democracy
by design.
They're not supposed to be 100% responsive
to public outrage or public reaction.
They're supposed to be somewhat insulated
from that.
So from that point of view, if you think that
future of American democracy is good, then
you probably shouldn't show up at outside
a Supreme Court justices house.
And, you know, yeah, there are I mean, the
point of democracy, I think, is that we have
these.
I really view democracy not as a system that
produces the best policies all the time.
I think that's actually too generous.
I think what it does better than other systems
of government is channel the inevitable outrage
of different factions into a nonviolent process,
which is if you can vote, it releases a lot
of the steam and anger that humans will always
build up about intense issues.
And it's like it's like a release valve on
that steam where you can go to the ballot
box instead of the battlefield.
And it's essentially a civil war prevention
mechanism, in my view.
And so when I see things inching closer to
violence and which is not to say that people
who show up outside these folks houses are
violent, but we know how these things sort
of spill over sometimes.
Yeah, I do think it's it's worth encouraging
people to, you know, reminding them that we
do live in a democracy.
You do have, you know, electoral means of
influencing the laws in your state.
And that's probably the wiser way to go.
Speaker 1: This sort of connects also to the
issue of I mean, the the sort of prototypical
situation is a speaker goes to a college campus
and they were invited.
Often it's by a conservative group on campus,
which often is the minority on campus.
I will readily admit, or at least on some
campuses, it's the minority.
And then there are protesters against the
speaker, and sometimes they're outside the
building, but sometimes they're inside and
will rise up as the speech is about to start.
And to me, that's not really about free speech
per say in the sense of nobody has a right
to speak at a college.
So not being invited is not a violation of
anything.
But at the same time, if you're invited, it
seems to me that it's reasonable to expect
that you can at least get your thoughts out
and then during question and answer or whatever.
But then the counter always is when I kind
of go this direction.
COLEMAN People saying it's not if you just
stick to the norms, you'll never really get
anything done.
By definition, activism that has an impact
may be inclusive of speech that isn't comfortable
or isn't being done exactly when it's allowed.
And it gets to the idea of the free speech
zone that was generated during George W Bush's
presidency, where, yes, you're allowed to
protest.
But in this box a hundred feet from the venue,
for example, how do you think that ties in
in terms of the speech of the speaker versus
the speech of those who say, I don't like
this speaker?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So the first thing I would say is I think
there's a big difference between protesting
inside the event which drowns out the speech
and protesting outside.
At Columbia, I witnessed lots of protests
like robust protests outside.
And those are totally, totally valid.
And they get the point across.
They definitely get the point across that
a lot of people object to the speaker.
But I've said you don't have the right to
just interrupt any event that you want because
you hate the person and drown it out.
So.
But to to your second point.
This idea that, you know, you have to play
dirty to get things done.
Right.
And the other side is there's bigotry and
there's evil and there's all this stuff.
So if we play by the rules, if we, you know,
we're just going to get whatever.
I don't I really disagree with that.
I mean, if you look at, for one thing, the
most successful protest movement, I would
argue, in the history of the country, which
was the civil rights movement.
They they they took it very seriously to play
by certain norms.
Because they understood that it was actually
strategically important to do so.
So, for example, during the March on Washington,
which was organized by Bayard Rustin and the
famous 63 March on Washington, where Martin
Luther King gave the I Have a Dream speech.
Bayard Rustin At the end of that day, she
went to a Philip Randolph and.
Like embraced him and congratulated him on
the fact that there was not a single crime
at the whole event with thousands and thousands
of people.
You understand what a difficult thing it is
to manage that.
Like BLM had so many protests and I went to
many in New York where at the beginning a
local BLM leader would say this is a peaceful
protest.
They would emphasize that with a bullhorn.
And still there would always be five or ten
people that ended up doing something crazy
and starting right.
So it's incredibly difficult to actually police
the boundaries within a protest and make sure
no one crosses those boundaries so that you
come across principled and persuasive to people
that don't already agree with you.
I think many protesters, they underestimate
the backlash phenomenon, which is when you
go too far, when you demonstrate that you're
willing to like say, you know, like Charles
Murray and Allison Stanger when that happened,
that overland right to initiate violence,
you lose a lot of of good faith among persuadable
people that see you as as violent and dangerous
revolutionaries that should be in charge of
nothing.
Right.
And even if a lot of people will only silently
form that opinion, I think a lot of modern
protest movements fail to recognize that wisdom,
which civil rights leaders really understood
deeply.
Speaker 1: I guess I, I'm generally sensitive
to that perspective.
The the counter that I have is that there
are a non-significant there is a not insignificant
contingent which will frame any protest as
violent anyway.
Now, that doesn't justify any violence.
I'm still against any violence and criminality.
But also, even if you say, okay, well, we're
not going to do any physical violence, but
we will, for example, shut down a road to
make our presence more known.
Because if we just stay on the sidewalk, we're
really not even going to have the impact that
we think we need.
I think the concern is that there are actors
who will say whatever is being done other
than basically being invisible is wrong and
is a form of violence regardless.
And then the question becomes, how do you
deal with the bad faith criticisms that will
come either way?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
I mean, to me, I think there is.
You know, if I were in charge of a protest
movement.
Sure.
I think that this strategic wise route is
to demonstrate moral seriousness.
That is, you know, every every protest movement
that has really looked back on as something
that made major gains for society, whether
it be Gandhi in India or the civil rights
movement or the marriage equality movement.
It it.
Key to their success was that they demonstrated
that they were morally serious people that
wanted to improve and not simply tear down.
And the way to do that, even if you're even
if you're disobeying the law in the context
of civil disobedience, is like Rosa Parks
disobeyed the law.
Martin Luther King disobeyed the law.
They got arrested dozens and dozens of times.
They were.
In that sense, they were not.
I mean, they were not just acquiescing to
anything or they were willing to disobey laws
all the time.
But precisely because they were doing that,
they took very seriously the aim to demonstrate
that they were morally serious people.
They were not disobeying the law just to disobey
the law.
They were disobeying it because they thought
it needed to be changed.
And they were right.
And it's again, there are so many failed protests,
movements, protest movements that that get
very little accomplished.
I think.
It would be very unwise to not observe the
differences between the ones that work and
the ones that don't.
And that's one of the big ones.
Speaker 1: Are there specific so part of the
examples you gave as positively include a
sort of assessment by you partially with the
benefit of hindsight now as to kind of the
intentions?
And I'm wondering in terms of tactics, I mean,
I think sometimes in environmental protests
there's the chaining oneself to ax and sometimes
it's a tree or sometimes it's the fence at
a nuclear power plant or whatever the case
may be.
Does the tactic itself tell you much about
the the moral concerned?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think the tactic tells
you a lot about the moral concerns.
So, for instance, if the tactic is maybe too
obvious to say, but if the tactic is violent,
it automatically legitimates the moral concern
in most people's eyes.
Okay.
It's like if your even, you know, I guess
this is unless.
Right.
So if you're just a terrorist, if you're an
environmental terrorist and you shoot somebody,
no one is going.
Very few people are going to be persuaded.
Certainly Congress is not going to be persuaded
by that kind of a protest.
If your tactic is nonviolent, if you spell
out exactly what your principles are and why
you're violating some law.
Then that demonstrates a kind of moral seriousness.
And that's an actual appeal to the public.
Right.
And moreover, to be willing to suffer on behalf
of your principles, like to Martin Luther
King was so committed to nonviolence in a
way that requires such extreme restraint,
right.
To literally be beaten and saying that's the
ultimate demonstration of moral seriousness.
It's like, I'm so serious about this moral
principle and getting it in the right means
that I'm willing to subject myself to this.
That was extremely persuasive to people.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: Absolutely fascinating topic.
We've been speaking with Coleman Hughes.
You can check out Coleman's podcast Conversations
with Coleman, on which I am a forthcoming
guest.
Coleman, always great chatting with you.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Anytime, David.